the time for talking is over Rishi sunak
believes and now it's time for a deal on
the Northern Ireland protocol
after months of talks with political
leaders in Northern Ireland and in
Europe the Prime Minister appears to be
on the brink of Landing a historic
brexit deal
but the Disclosure by Sky News that King
Charles was being lined up to play a key
ceremonial role in the final stages of
negotiations has hardened the dup's
opposition not only is the prime
minister naive if that's what he was
planning to do but this is a cynical use
or an abuse of the king he knows it the
king's intervention would be seen by
many of our supporters as an endorsement
of the deal and he also knows of course
in doing so he was dragging the king
into a hugely controversial political
issue
the King was close to being deployed by
number 10 to meet the European
commission president Ursula Von de Lyon
with a signing of a new brexit deal
expected imminently the meeting has now
been canceled
the leading Tory you're a skeptic MP
Jacob Reese mogg told Sky News bringing
in the king would border on
constitutional impropriety
reinforcing The View that a deal may be
imminent conservative MPS have been put
on a three-line whip to be here in the
Commons on Monday but leading you're a
skeptic Tory MPS also tell me they fear
they're going to be bounced into
accepting Mr sunax deal with little or
no time to study the detail
in a Blow to Mr sunac's hopes of winning
over brexiteers the former prime
minister Boris Johnson has signaled he
may not back the PM's deal I think the
the best way forward as I've as I said
when I was uh running the government is
is the Northern Ireland Bill
urging him instead to pass his own bill
giving ministers powers to defy Brussels
for two years businesses have faced
chaos as a result of Border checks under
the Northern Ireland protocol Mr sunac
hopes that's about to change